لم يتبقى مني كول سوى ذكرى والصوره يحملها
والدها بحثا عن عداله لبنه فقدها في
انفجار مرفا بيروت وبعد ان طالبه اكثر من
عامين باستجواب المتهمين فتى هو متهم
بالمشاركه باعمال شغب شهدها محيط قصر
العدل
هو واحد من تسعه من اهالي الضحايا تم
استدعائهم للتحقيق
ضحاياكم
تسوى الدنيا
الى ساحه قصر العدل عاده اهالي الضحايا
للوقوف بالمرصاد لمحاولات التعيين قادم
نظيف للقاضي طارق البيطار محاولات نجحت في
منع انعقاد جلسه مجلس القضاء الاعلى لكن
الخوف يتملك الاهالي من محاولات السلطه
المستمره لشل التحقيقات لذلك تستمر
محاولاتهم لتدويل قضيتهم في قضيه
بريطانيا
امريكا همم برج الشركه الملك شركه سبكترون
طالب بنكمل وعن نضغط هلا تيسير في لجنه
تكاثر الحقيقيه
لفات من قاضي لحتى ينحط قاضي اخر محله هذا
بيسمح مجله تدخلات السياسيه يا اللي اكيد
هي للضحك في قاضي مستلم هذا الملف بيقدر
يرجع على شغله صار له سنه ممنوع عن العمل
هناك حلول لايعته الى العمل غير تعيين
قاضي بديل لا ينفي بعض الاهالي تواصلهم مع
القاضي الفرنسي الذي سيصل نهايه الشهر الى
بيروت لعل زيارته تعيد العدل الى ساحه
الجريمه لم تعمل السلطه اللبنانيه على
تجميد تحقيقات انفجار المرفق لمنع استجواب
المتورطين فقط بل حاولت الضحيه الى جلاد
وبات الاهالي هم المطالبون اليوم بالتوجه
الى غرف التحقيقات غنوا يتيم العربيه
بيروت